what if you can inspect a machine
learning model with minimal code
required what if you could even see if
your model was being fair or not we'll
cover all that and more on today's
episode of a I adventures
[Music]
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to look
at the what if tool an open source
project from the people and AI research
team at Google it's designed to help you
probe your models to better understand
its behavior now a few episodes ago we
looked at lucid which was great for
understanding convolutional networks
it's only fitting that we now look at
the what if tool which specializes in
structured data and text let's take a
look at what it looks like the wit of
tool or wit can be used inside a Jupiter
or collab notebook or embed it into a
the tensor board web application today
well just look at one example data set
our old friend the US Census data set
it's a nicely sized data set for this
type of exploration and it has many of
the flaws of a real-world data set so we
can have some pretty interesting
findings in this example two models were
trained on the census data set a linear
classifier and a deep classifier so
they'll be compared to each other as we
use the tool within the tool they're
referred to as model one and model two
the first view of the wouldve tool has
facets dive embedded in it you can use
it to slice and dice your data along the
x and y axes as well as see how your
data points are distributed longtime
viewers will recall an early episode of
AI adventures about the facets tool if
you were wondering whatever happened to
that well here's your answer the fastest
tool has been integrated into the what
if tool and update with more features
facets dive is incredibly flexible and
can create multiple interesting
visualizations through its ability to
bucket scatter and color data points you
can click on values in the chart and
edit them to see what the prediction
would be for your newly edited value try
doing this near the decision
boundary to get up better understanding
of what features have a greater effect
on the outcome of your predictions here
we change the age and hours per week of
a data point to see if that changes the
outcome of the prediction and by how
much
notice that the predictions for both the
linear model and a deep model are shown
here this view also features an ability
to show the nearest counterfactuals the
nearest counterfactual is the most
similar data point that got a different
classification once you turn on the
toggle each time you click a data point
its counterfactual also gets highlighted
here we see an example where these two
data points are very similar but the
occupations are different now let's move
over to the next tab yeah this tool has
got two more tabs of information the
next one is called performance and
fairness which allows us to look at
overall model performance and ask
questions about model performance across
data slices be sure to set that ground
truth feature in the upper left which is
the label that we'll be predicting on in
order to get the most out of this panel
we can try moving the prediction
threshold around for each of the models
to see how it impacts that confusion
matrix we can also choose the slice by
up to two fields and then select various
fairness optimization strategies to see
how that affects the threshold values in
each model now the third tab is not to
be left out here we see facets overview
embedded into the what if tool you can
use this to look at the distribution of
your data points across all the
different features as well as some key
information about each feature this is a
great way to spot imbalance data as well
there's a lot of features a lot of use
cases for the what-if tool so we're not
going to be able to cover them all today
but if you're interested in learning
more about it let me know in the
comments below or on Twitter and I'll
try to make another episode to dive into
the other features of this tool in more
detail and if you can't wait for that to
happen go ahead and join the what-if
tool community on our Google Group there
you'll find announcements of new
features and all sorts of lively
discussions I've included a clickable
link below in the description thanks for
watching this episode of cloudy I
adventures and if you enjoyed it click
the
like button and be sure to subscribe to
get all the latest episodes right when
they come out for now check out the wit
of tool and learn about how your model
is operating
[Music]